[Music]
we are doing a new Ghostbusters movie
and I heard this are you gonna answer
that Ghostbusters what do you want a lot
of the original cast seems to be heavily
involved more than cameos from the 2016
1 Sigourney Weaver says she's coming
back do you have anything to tell us
here today
hmm aye that sounds correct I think that
might be happening and I'm I'm I think
also that I might be a part of that and
you know Ivan Reitman is very talented
son Jason I believe is following in his
father's footsteps and apparently has
come up with a wonderful idea
I have not seen a script but again it's
it's neither is it a project where you
go now I want to do that I mean bill
might say that yeah but I feel like if
Jason if Jason Reitman calls yeah annie
potts us yes right Jorge said yes I I I
think she would in a hypothetical world
oh my think that that would be true yeah
it wouldn't be right without you I
really wouldn't
[Music]
alright sheriff let's do this there's a
new toy story on the horizon and while
we've missed Woody and Buzz we finally
get to find out where Bo Peep has been
the character is fabulous and and with
this story the line for four she has as
you can see she's broken through into
the boys club right so yes she's quite a
girl now woody suck decided to that he
needed to stay with his child instead of
his love and so she's been you know had
her heart broken and then she got
stuffed away in an antique store and so
she's kind of lost everything but she
has managed to overcome all that and is
super happy and confident and having a
wonderful life serving children in a
broader way
open your eyes woody there's plenty of
kids out there
well Toy Story 3 we kind of thought that
was the last time we were gonna see all
the toys was there any like were you
bummed that you really didn't get to
complete both story at that time and did
you ever think that Toy Story 4 was
gonna happen that you were gonna be able
to do that you know I hadn't thought
much about it characters come and go and
it was busy I didn't even I didn't even
know that they were doing at Toy Story 3
until it came out it was like oh I was
like I I don't think I'm in there but I
hadn't imagined it I would I would come
back and then I got a call saying yeah
oh yeah she's back and she's a major
character and and this will explain
where she was in three I want to mention
the designing women' revival because
this was I think about a year ago yeah
it was announced there was going to be a
revival there was talks of it I think at
one point you said I'm definitely
wanting to be involved has there been
any movement yes you know I don't know
what's happening with that right now I
hope it happens I think you know if
there's I think there is desire for it
and I think that there's energy behind
it it's just a matter of where it's
gonna be I think they've got you know
our writer
creator very talented and I think more
than ever we need voices we need those
women's voices and I think to hear them
from a southern framework is also
important and you know likewise the
Pixar people were very very right to
bring a female character forward because
we shouldn't keep hearing from every
corner all the time that men are so much
better than we are and so much more
capable and so much more interesting and
so much more active sheriff would he
always coming to the rescue
years ago my my oldest son who was a
very gifted writer he was about seven
years old and I was making dinner
reading a script at the same time and
and he was trying to get a little
attention from me and he said what
script are you reading and I said I
don't know I just started it and I'm not
sure I'm stirring the pot in this and he
goes well you know they're only three
characters in any movie I went really
and he said yes there's the good guy and
the bad guy and the woman who waits this
is a child a child has a has made this
assessment and I thought you're right
yeah the woman's either waiting tables
she's serving food to the men or packing
their bag for them so they can have an
adventure mm-hmm
and I thought this sucks and I thought
I'm never gonna play a woman who hates
again unless it's to prove the point
that that is a completely ridiculous
role to always put women in yeah so Bo
Peep is definitely not waiting on
anybody yeah
I'm sorry guys it's over it's now
obvious we're superior to you in every
way Israel
sorry wait a star and bow is back and
she's thriving I'm so excited
me too yeah thank you so much thank you
for coming great to talk to you
Bo Peep returns June 21st don't miss it
she's waiting on no one there's the tag
line right there
[Music]
you
[Music]